all right so Donald Trump held two
rallies over the weekend we are really
getting into just the very very end here
of the 2022 midterm campaign period we
have debates this week next week the
week after I'll be live streaming a
bunch of them Donald Trump's rally
schedule has gotten very busy and each
of these rallies Wilder and crazier than
the previous let's go in reverse
chronological order Donald Trump
speaking Sunday night or afternoon as it
were in Arizona in support of Kerry Lake
and Blake Masters and other really
dangerous extreme candidates Donald
Trump was completely completely
completely incoherent talking about the
planting of documents jumping back and
forth between they were my documents and
I had the right to have them at
Mar-A-Lago
to they planted the documents listen to
this making no sense soaking wet Trump
dripping wet as he tells these lies
National Archives put a trigger warning
on the Constitution of the United States
did you know that and the Bill of Rights
and other great documents that we have
in our country founding documents
trigger considering them to be dangerous
they consider the Constitution
to be dangerous these are radical left
lunatics and they lose documents they
plant documents oh let's see is there a
book on nuclear destruction or the
building of a nuclear weapon cheaply
let's put that box let's put that book
in with Trump
no they plant documents I mean they have
a terrible reputation so Trump now
saying despite at the very same rally
saying listen these were my documents
they took them they got to give them
back they're my documents now he's
saying well they planted stuff and it
included a book on how to make a nuke
wow that's a new allegation I hadn't
heard that before Trump then says listen
everything they found was mine they
should give it all back wait but I
thought you said they planted the stuff
was it yours or was it not yours
they don't get enough credit by contrast
I had a small number of boxes in storage
at Mar-A-Lago guarded by secret service
and my people and everybody I mean it's
safe when you look at
these other people what they did and the
FBI rated my home and violated my fourth
amendment rights and many other rights
and under the Sox decision this is a
very important decision that was made to
court the Sox decision because again it
had to do with Bill Clinton and his
socks
there is no crime you know there is no
crime it's not a crime and
they should give me immediately back
everything that they've taken from
because it's mine right oh wait but I
thought you said they planted it so now
he says it's his stuff give it back fine
but for a while like five minutes
earlier the story was the stuff was
planted another completely unbelievable
moment Arizona gubernatorial Republican
candidate Kerry Lake talks about Hunter
Biden's crack pipe really elevating the
discourse at these rallies now I gotta
tell you yeah I have some of these know
nothing can Consultants who tell me you
know you really need to back away from
president Trump right now
[Applause]
right now
wouldn't it be horrible wouldn't it be
horrible what would it say about my
character if I stepped away from my
friends if I step away from my friends
that means I would step away from you
and I will never step away from the
people of Arizona
and so for those know-nothing
consultants and the media I want to show
you what it looks like when I step away
from president Trump show us
and gives Trump a big hug there so
really just out of control with the
hunter Biden stuff and then uh she and
by the way she could win she's leading
by like a point or two right now she
that woman could be the next governor of
Arizona as scary and horrifying as that
is and then uh Donald Trump now also the
anti-trans and parents rights portion of
these speeches it's a staple at every
rally now
one of the first things we must do is
stand up for parents rights can you
believe I'm even saying that we're going
to fight for parents rights who would
ever think you have to say that
we're going to fight for parents rights
10 years ago if you said that they say
you're crazy what of course you're going
to fight for parents rates today you
have to make a case for it we will get
critical race Theory out of our schools
out of our military which we had it out
and out of every part of our federal
state and local governments and at long
last every parent in America must be
empowered to opt out of the forced
indoctrination in the classroom and send
their child to the public private
Charter religious or home school of
their choice then he goes on to say no
teacher should be allowed to teach
transgender whatever that means without
parental permission so that is now a
staple of the rallies that's the Arizona
rally Trump dripping wet confused
extreme but that was nothing compared to
the previous day's rally in Nevada which
is where we're going to go next one of
our sponsors is Helix sleep I have been
sleeping on a helix mattress for years
and I always recommend it to friends
you'd simply take this Helix sleep quiz
it asks you about your body type your
sleep position whether you have back
pain and and then Helix will match you
up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason I went
with Helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single Helix mattress is made in the USA
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you're
supporting great jobs I'm not the only
one who loves Helix Helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine every Helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the David packman show by
getting your next mattress from Helix
sleep and you'll get up to 350 off any
mattress plus two free pillows when you
go to helixsleep.com Pacman the link is
down below